good morning my name is Barry d'harans I
am the security PM for all of dark net
and you get various other things that I
just can't get rid of even though I
would dearly love to today we're gonna
talk about security and asp.net core 2.1
we're gonna cover some things that we're
in too because some of you might not
know it and I'm not going to make the
assumption that everyone is already
migrated to core although obviously you
should be so my job title in the
Microsoft global address list is dotnet
security curmudgeon because I am grumpy
and horrible and chain smoke and swear
at people as my colleagues in the front
row can attest to I generally get to
annoy everybody about coding securely I
tell them what to do and then cry when
David Fowler doesn't do it and then I
have to cope and clean up Fowler's mess
when things go horribly wrong if you
want to follow me on Twitter or tag me
on Twitter I am a blow dart it is not a
particularly work focused account it has
lots of swear words and lots of pictures
of my dog so I'm gonna go through a
bunch of things I can go through hosting
authentication authorization little bits
of identity with a preview of what we're
planning to do in 2.2 well a little bit
after 2.2 but we're gonna start off with
this thing that makes me worry the most
which is hosting and hosting means
Castrol kestrel is the asp.net core web
server it has scared me for the last
three years that we decided we would
like to write our own web server again
and abandon iis which of course is not
cross-platform so I can see the business
reasons we're doing it but writing a web
server from scratch is a security
nightmare we've had it tested by a bunch
of external security firms you always go
wait you've just written a web server
and you want us to bash on it and they
get really big grins and get very very
excited so what we have done into one is
we have turned on HTTPS by default it is
everywhere now and all our templates you
will have HTTPS we have a tool that will
generate a developer cert for you and
Trust it on Windows if your own Linux
trusting it is your own problem because
Linux doesn't really have a security
story which is a whole other
presentation but its own by default you
can take a box that says don't use HTTPS
if you do this you are a horrible person
HTTP is everywhere now Chrome gets
really upset if your website is not on
HTTPS edge will probably follow about
two years behind because that's what
edge does so that's why we what that's
why it's there you are testing in sort
of the same environment that you'll be
running in production keep HTTPS on and
we really think casual HTTP can be
config so you can have different
certificates based on your environment
it can be selected automatically based
on subject name and expiry date that
means it will rotate and we have support
for sni so SN is when you have multiple
HTTP web servers listening on the same
ip address and so the initial connection
comes in and cache all will get it and
you can look at where it's going to go
via the host header and send the right
HTTPS certificate back and like I say we
have a tool because generating
self-signed cert on Windows is a pain in
the ass even in PowerShell so we decided
to make it a little bit easier for you
so dotnet dev certs
is the tool because everything is a
dotnet global tool these days and it'll
create it will delete all one's it will
push through the trust on Windows so
certificate config works a little bit
like this you can tell it where to get
it from which on Windows is the Windows
Store on Linux it's a random file
sitting on your filesystem unprotected
because Linux has no security story and
if you have it in config we will wire it
up even if you don't have it in config
we will look for ones based on local
so the config only really comes into
play when you're moving towards your
production environment like I say we
have sni so that's a nice a little bit
complicated here we have certificate
selection we are going to listen import
5005 and we have a bunch of listen
options so we load all our certs up and
then in the HTTP options we set a server
certificate selector and it will get the
name of the certificate that it's going
to look for which is the domain name and
you can do a selection based upon it and
return the right sir or return the
default and then get loads of browser
errors web servers needs tuning
everything nice tuning is has tuning
engine access tuning Apache has tuning
and kestrel is no exception
there are rather a lot of tuning options
we've tried to make these things safe by
default depending on your environment
you may need to adjust things keep a
lifetime rights for example we've
selected four reasonably fast internet
but because you're in Australia that
does not exist here you may need to
increase time i'ts for people who are in
Tasmania for example there are lots of
reasons to ban people from Tasmania but
again that's a another another talk more
sensibly you know if you are sending
things to Africa where people are on
really old cellular connections you will
need to adjust your timeouts but by
default we've chosen things that are
reasonably appropriate for normal non
Australian connections they probably
work with Australian connections too I
shouldn't pick on Australian internet
too much but I've had to suffer with it
since Sunday because we've put HTTPS on
by default we also have a bunch of
options we will add HTTP redirection so
if you hit the HTTP site it will
redirect you up
HTTP and you can configure that as you
can see by saying services options some
people like to think that they just want
to redirect up to HTTPS for a login page
and then redirect down again that's a
horrible idea and we don't support it so
don't do it and then we have h sts this
slide came I have a really long
conversation on Twitter with a bunch of
people who work on Chrome HSTs is a flag
that when you hit a site over SSL for
the first time you can send this header
it will say never ever load this site
again over HTTP even if the customer
types in HTTP in the URL location and
it's great except for when it's not HH
SDS is dangerous because it persists
once you've sent that header you send it
with at I might value and which
eventually clears out of the browser
after that time is expired but trying to
clear it beforehand is really really
hard
I have HSTs turned on on my website
because I trusted a sure to renew my SSL
certificate last year that failed I no
longer had an SSL certificate it did not
rotate it ended up expired and HSTs pin
sites will not load if there are
problems with the certificate thank you
Azure someone got a really rude email
the next morning so HSTs is great and
you should enable it
but you only enable it once you've
trusted all your certificate
infrastructure here are all the problems
that you have did you really want to
cover all your subdomains did you forget
a test site that's running off your
production demand don't do that get
another get another demand for all your
test sites how fast can you roll your
certificate if the certificate has been
accidentally revoked how fast can you
get a new one do your certificates
actually Auto renew does it work thanks
ah sure what happens if the CA has been
pulled out of Chrome's trust as has
happened with a bunch of CAS recently
that funnily enough
pal are still using I think in a month
if paypal does not rotate their certs
Chrome will no longer trust it what
happens you got a bad revoke how fast
can you move from one CA to another are
you monitoring your certificate status
do you send something to your site every
five minutes that will send an HTTP
request look at the certificate make
sure it's still valid and alert you if
it's not these are the things you need
to take into account when you're going
to use HSTs so when you run out into
production start with a really sure
expiration start with five minutes and
once you've got five minutes and that's
been running for a week to two weeks
okay you think you're good
increase it to an hour and then a couple
of months later and crease it to a week
and eventually ramp it up to where you
are at I my HSTs flag is going to be for
a year and once you've had it working
for six months then you can consider pre
loading it pre loading is where HSTs
status are baked into browser builds so
our request doesn't even need to be sent
chrome will know that your site is in
the HSTs list and it will just send
everything over HTTP and as does it as
well so an asp.net core we defaults to
30 days for your HSTs expiration and
it's kind of a bad compromise between
the five minutes that's recommended by a
chrome and edge for pre loading and the
year that everyone expects you to end up
in so use it but remember it is a
commitment that nothing will ever go
wrong with your cert infrastructure you
may get called at midnight when your
cert expires and as your forgot to roll
it so we added here using AB dot use
HSTs and then we set a bunch of options
preload is where you can say that your
sites in the preload list includes sub
demands max age and we exclude hosts and
a bunch of other stuff it's STS will not
work on localhost we hard-coded that
because it's so hard to clear HSTs
status in your browsers that if we put
it on low
host and then you decided to spin up
another test website and not didn't have
HTTPS because you hit puppies and
kittens the browser would still try and
load over HSTs so localhost is excluded
from all of this so if you start trying
to trace things and fiddler and wonder
why you are not getting an HSTs editor
on your dev site running on localhost
this is why we are protecting you from
yourself so kestrel what when we had
initially launched it in version 1 we
said please run up behind a proxy run it
behind I asked to run it behind nginx
and everyone went no we want the speed
and I'm like but it's a new web server
from version 2 of dotnet core onwards we
will support you exposing kestrel
directly to the Internet but I will
underscore again that this is new web
server code we believe it's secure we've
had a couple of we've had a couple of
interesting bugs over the last few
months and we've pushed our kestrel
updates there was one last month so if
you are going to expose kestrel directly
you need to pay very close attention to
the github announcements repo for
asp.net on Patch Tuesday because we
don't push darknet core patches over
Windows Update because that wouldn't
work on Linux and we made a promise that
we would never patch underneath you
because sometimes patches break people
so you all need to be subscribed to the
announcements repo on github for asp.net
and for dotnet if you're gonna expose
Castrol directly to the Internet because
you will need to patch in a timely
manner so we've got hosting by the way
and then we have authentication knowing
who you are in our templates we have
support for no authentication we have
supports for individual user accounts
which is asp.net identity plus a bunch
of other stuff we have work in school
accounts so that's a sure ad and we have
windows authentication that only runs on
Windows we have had a bunch of requests
from people saying we would like
integrated in Windows authentication in
our Linux containers
that has made me cry so much that I'm
actually now thinking about it because
when those authentication underneath the
hood is in fact Kerberos authentication
and I believe we can support it on Linux
if you want to take a dependency on
samba which is an interesting idea from
a security perspective but we are
starting to look at that now so if you
are running in an ad environment and you
are running in Linux containers because
you don't want to pay all your windows
licensing fees and you still want that
smooth login of no one ever having to
type anything in we might get there
it'll be 3.0 or 3.1 and we have social
authentication built in so we have
Facebook Twitter Google Microsoft
account and ooofff and there is a ton of
social identification services that are
in that github repo in the asp.net
contrib repo there are some really weird
ones of of social networks I've never
heard before but pretty much everything
is going to be in there that you will
ever need so individual user accounts
like I say we have a local database so
you are committing to having a database
somewhere that will never ever leaked to
the internet because bad evil hackers
got at it you may wish to accept that
risk you may not if you don't want to
accept that risk there is as your b2c
some people like it some people don't
then there are other things you can have
like identity server which still
requires a database on the back end you
have a sauce and an open eye deck and
and if you are stuck in government how
many people here are working in
government that would like to admit it
mmm for those people stuck in government
we have support for WS fed finally that
came I just after 2.0 so you can stick
with those really really old but
actually really secure authentication
providers that government demands
because they haven't moved on since the
1990s the template off we will have our
local debt database you can configure
your EF models for accounts and groups
and everything else we
quite opinionated about it we don't
allow you to change our password saving
algorithms because we don't trust you to
make the right decisions I'm sorry but
that's true so we have a bunch of
reasonable compromises between speed of
hashing and security and we review those
with every minor release and we can
tweak them somewhat and move things on
for work and school accounts we have
asked your Active Directory and that's
using OID see underneath look this slide
is now I have debt because it says no WS
fed support so we support ad FS as well
so if you're working in an old
networking environment where you haven't
moved to Azure ad and you still want to
do federated login with your Active
Directory you can use WS fed or you can
use ad FS with oh I DC and then like I
say windows authentication which needs
iis you can't expose Castrol directly
for windows off you're gonna have to
join your service to the demand which is
an interesting idea from a security
point of view and there is no
impersonation it used to be that when
people used integrated off to iis then
IAS would run a process as that person
we don't do that because we think it's a
terrible idea
you then have to specifically choose
when you want to impersonate which
usually is when you want to talk to a
database and then it will automatically
Emperor unimpressive it once it's done
so for those of you that haven't moved
to core and have are still stuck on the
classic asp.net framework there are a
few changes everything now is a claims
principle we have multiple pieces of
identification well it's not middleware
anymore but it's close enough you can
have multiple ways to authenticate
within the same app so you could have
Facebook and Twitter and Google and
local databases and WS fair and oh I D
see all at once you can cherry-pick
which one to use depending on where you
want to go and you can run one
automatically at a time
if you have multiple ones you have to
choose which one is your man one which
is generally cookie and then you can
pick and choose what gets triggered when
you go to certain endpoints or by
calling sign in in your code and we have
cookie authentication which is the
backbone of everything that's generally
how your identity is going to be
persisted through the browser in a nice
encrypted in sign cookie and it finally
understands the difference between
authenticated and forbidden which for
the longest time it did not so everybody
got the same login prompt no matter what
they tried to do so in core 2 we changed
it so authentication is now a single
service it's not exactly middleware
anymore like I said it's services within
the service and we have this this whole
thing between active and passive that
was a real mess in 1.0 and we fixed it
in 2.0 so this is this whole I want to
choose my default Authenticator and
everything else is optional it was
really easy to mess that up in one you
were only ever supposed to mark one
piece of authentication middleware as
active and the rest would be passive and
then you do your picking and choosing
but there was no enforcement of that so
you ended up if you had more than one
piece of active middleware and what we
euphemistically called an unsupported
state which is a nice say not nice way
of saying we don't know what the hell's
going to happen now so we have enforced
that now if you are migrating from one
to two these are the changes that you
will need to make it used to be a dot
use and then the middleware and now we
have services don't add and then in
configure we have user authentication
and here is how we set our defaults so
if you are supporting for example social
off
we have default challenge scheme default
sign-in scheme and default
authentication now this is worth
explaining so if I do a social login say
I go to Facebook and I come back and I
get an identity from Facebook I need to
save it somewhere so every single
request doesn't go through this first
call because that would be irritating as
hell so when I say that generally a
default that you want for everything is
cookie that's what we end up doing you
do your Facebook often and we write it
to a cookie that is dropped on the
machine so in the v2 section down here
what we have is we have our default
sign-in scheme which is cookie we have
our default authenticate scheme which is
cookie on our challenge scheme which is
off to OID CR off to Facebook so
challenge happens when someone tries to
access a protected resource and they are
not logged in so when you hit something
that has the authentic it attribute on
it
we will go off to Facebook but sign in
and sign in and authenticate our cookies
because that helps us rehydrate from the
cookie on every single request we don't
want those to be Facebook or OID C
because that won't work because every
single request you would get both start
and come back in again and it would be
horrible does that make sense okay and
then if you are migrating from 1 to 2
you're really behind the times you
should have done that last year we've
changed how things work so instead of
everything being in HP net core HTTP
authentication we've done just moved it
up to authentication and you use
contacts that authenticates challenge
and sign in to trigger all these things
if you forget to make it you get a
weird-ass error or you get warning
saying you're using deprecated code and
if you want to do everything yourself if
you hit the templates that we give you
for asp.net identity and that's fine
I honestly don't care I would like to
know why you hit them but you know
that's what get help issues before you
can do everything yourself you can use
our cookie middleware or our cookie
services and get the security that we
built into those with your own identity
so you can go off and use the database
of your own and then instead of having
to figure out how you want to secure it
encrypt cookies to save that identity
through requests use our stuff it is
properly documented we properly
comenta this in one point home we've
kept the documentation up-to-date unlike
previous versions of the framework where
there was no documentation for this
whatsoever so the cookie stuff will
encrypt ensign cookies it uses data
protection so you can synchronize your
keys across multiple instances of your
website and you don't have to worry
about this so here's how we can
configure it we just add cookie
authentication with a cookie scheme name
and a scheme name is just basically a
key in a dictionary and then you call
sign in with a cookie scheme name and
the user principle that you want to
persist and you call sign I with a
cookie scheme name and everything else
is taken care of for you with each
request we will look for the cookie and
if it is there we will rehydrate the
identity for you and shove it on the
user property for the request for the
page for the controller for the action
it will be there for you and you don't
have to worry about it you can write
your own authentication handlers I've
got a couple of sample ones I've got one
for certificate authentication I've got
one for basic authentication which no
one should ever use in production but
people were bugging me so I wrote it
which would show you how to write your
own authentication handlers it's rare
that you'll need to do this if you do
need to do it I'd love to know what
you're trying to do please drop me an
email so once you drop a cookie it is
the sole source of truth because the
services will kick in and rehydrate
every single time we are not going back
to a database every single time because
that would be horrible in terms of
scalability but the cookie service has
the concept of a validator and in the
validator you can go back to a back-end
database yourself so say for example you
have an HR system you may well want to
go back to a database and check that the
user has not been fired in the last five
minutes you probably don't want to do
this in every single request because
like I say it's gonna kill scalability
but we have validators that can reject
the principle that has been rehydrate
from the cookie or it can even replace
them so someone gets promoted you could
change their job title on the website so
you wire this up in the options on the
cookie middleware we do this for you in
asp.net identity we refresh every 30
minutes and you can actually look at how
identity does it to figure I if that's
going to work for you here's how we
implement a validator it's not very
exciting replace means I don't want to
throw the user ID I'm just going to say
that they have new roles or they have
new properties reject that's what you
think it's going to do and then here's
how you wire up in the cookie
authentication events and we have
authentication forwarding which is new
into one so we finally got something
that's new into one so like I said we
could we have ways of wiring up multiple
authentication services so we have let's
say cookie authentication and then I
have a bunch of api's and hopefully
we're all aware because Troy has told us
that authenticate against api's with the
cookie is just really weird and you may
not have cookies if you were calling
them from phone apps or something else
and you want to use JA tokens because JA
tokens are the new hotness and no one
loves XML anymore and no one wants to do
WS star identity come to my public alpha
talk and I will tell you how wrong you
are and we supported this in version 1
and in version 2 you could choose the
scheme that you wanted to use during
authentication by putting it on a
property on the Authenticator attribute
or putting it in an authorization policy
which I'll come on to in a bit and that
was in my mind the right way to do it
you would apply it to a controller
because as you're well aware there are
multiple ways to route to a controller
and nobody should be doing anything
based on request path but because my
customers are horrible people all of you
want to do it based on request path so
now you can do it based on request path
if you want to make me sad
we have authentication forwarding so
each piece of each cookie or sorry each
authentication service has a forward
default selector option and in the
forward default selector option you can
write your own code so here we have I've
got cookie authentication setup and then
you can see that if my path starts with
slash API I'm gonna forward it to the
API authentication this is a scheme name
here so like I said we have scheme names
you can see up top I'm adding two I'm
adding like a scheme a fake API scheme
handler but then when a request comes in
the default will be cookie and then
cookie will go where this goes to slash
API so I'm gonna hand it off to the API
authentication handler so now you can
put this all in one place as opposed to
putting it in policies or in attributes
within your code and you can do things
based on path which may eventually help
if you want to do multi-tenancy does
that make sense have people been wanting
this
no one's gonna admit it because I'm
gonna tell you you're horrible
okay but we also have virtual schemes
which is a different way of doing
exactly the same thing because we never
like to give you one way to do things
we'd like to complicate things you can
set up a virtual scheme which is an
authentication scheme which has no
authentication in it it is just the
forwarding insight here so you would add
authentication and say I'm gonna use my
virtual scheme as my default and then we
add a policy scheme we have our virtual
scheme scheme name we have a display
name which you don't particularly need
to worry about and in our options we can
put a forward default selector in there
and choose which one we want to end up
with two ways of doing exactly the same
thing I like this way because then it's
not on individual options inside
handlers
and then there's API us so when we were
back in classic asp.net you could create
an API API project and say I want to add
individual authentication and we had an
authentication server built into
previous versions of asp.net and when we
moved to core I didn't want to bother
with writing and authentication server
anymore there are an awful lot of
authentication servers out there that
are much better than anything we could
produce identity server being the one
that springs to mind mainly because I
have their sticker on my laptop and so
that option went away and everybody said
I have an API and I want to add a
syndication to it what do I do and I'm
like you job bearer and the answer was
okay how do I get a job bearer token I'm
like ah you're on your own with that one
which is not a good story according to
management they would like us to you
know not tell customers they're on their
own so we've been kind of mulling over
what we wanted to do and adding identity
server or a sauce or open edict has been
historically complicated these things
generally tend to require you to know
more about oh i DC than you ever wanted
to know so we decided four to one and
all honestly this will probably come a
couple of months after t1 it will ship
out a band and then it will be properly
integrated in three we decided we wanted
to fill that gap and so we're like okay
we're going to add authentication for
API projects and here we have a sneak
peek of what we're going to do and when
we suggested we were going to do this
the community was somewhat
vocal I think is the polite way to put
it
you see we thought we would just we
could write a simple one that would do a
lot of the work for us and it was very
simple to configure and it was very
limited in what it would do just for API
first party API scenarios and a
community basically said wait you're
killing all these third party
authentication services you should use
those and we're like okay but you keep
telling us they're really really
complicated to set up and configuring
like nah we don't care use those stop
killing off other open source projects
which was never the idea in the first
place we were gonna give you a nice
migration path so we went and pull the
code that we'd written / happy ere all
his code got thrown away and it's like
okay make integration happen so we had
to pick who to integrate with and
because I already have their sticker
we chose identity server that is not the
reason we chose identity server please
don't quote me on that so here we have a
sneak peak of a work in progress the
names for some of these functions will
change because as sure as you're well
aware we suck at naming things so here
we have an API project and here we have
we're just gonna like use sequel server
we're gonna add asp.net identity to be
our backing database for this and we're
gonna add entity framework and then what
we'll make a bunch of you happy is we
add identity server and then below that
we're going to go add asp.net core
conventions that will change because it
sucks this is function name and we will
wire everything up for you and we get
really opinionated about this you don't
need to worry about generating your keys
anymore you don't need to worry about
scopes you don't want you to worry about
naming because we are going to have a
simple convention
best way of registering your
applications in identity server for you
at runtime so you don't have to worry
about any of the admittedly very
flexible configuration for identity
server but also the quite overwhelming
configuration for identity server and
then we're going to call services to out
of indication like we always do and then
we're gonna say hey look I've got a
local API in this project so I'm gonna
call add local API so here we have an
API controller ooh
it's the stunningly excited values
controller and of course they aren't
here we also have use identity server so
if I run this it worked last night I may
have pulled dot in the repo again this
morning so we'll see how this goes like
I say it's a work in progress you are
the first people to know that this is
going to be using identity server so if
you're going to tweet anything that's
the thing to tweet it will probably be
delayed by a couple months after two one
as we try and get different scenarios
working I want to get to the point where
you do new web API project and you
choose individual off with identity
server and then when you add a new API
project to your solution that will also
get wired up and I also want to get to
the point where API projects can
authenticate themselves to other API
projects as one project to another and
once we've got that and I'm happy that's
when we'll release and also it has to be
simple because I care about the
experience I don't want people to have
to write configuration for themselves
now when you sort of like move outside
our scenarios then you just you know you
drop back to using an identity server
with our helper classes and we will give
you a bunch of migration documents that
tell you these are the conventions that
we did here's how you do the manually an
identity server now you're adding more
stuff here's how you switch to going
from identity server with training
wheels to identity server with its big
turbo
so here we have a template prototype spa
client this will not be in the final
template this is just to prove that
everything works when the final
templates come around it will probably
just be a raffle so you can type code
kind of need to figure out how I can do
Oh IDC within a raffle but we'll solve
we'll think about that when it comes to
it so if I click login
this is identity server its identity
server embedded in your project there's
there's no identity server controllers
or anything whole UI is embedded just
like we have done with asp.net identity
so if I log in here
and I remember my password and it hasn't
broken
oh dear what chance your have to go
there we go no your Logan there we go so
I am logged in now I have gotten the job
token back it's not cookies anymore
and because I have a job token and it's
saved in the browser as a job token
using brought local storage I can call
an API using the same methods that I
would use to call it from a mobile app
so we have the same authentication
mechanisms between our web app and our
mobile app and I lo longer have to
support two different types of
authentication so I can call the API and
it's good old values controller and
that's not sending a cookie anymore it
is sending a job token using identity
servers client for these things their
JavaScript client for doing requests so
we have integration with the communities
probably most popular authenticate third
party authentication service and you can
still keep everything local I mean you
could obviously do this with off the
zero as well if you want to like have
all their stuff stored in the cloud but
I'd any server seems to be where it's at
and it is incredibly flexible and can do
all sorts of wonderful magical things so
that will come maybe a couple of months
after 2.1 and there will be templates
and there will be magic and it will all
be gloriously documented and you won't
have to worry about configuration
because we will know there is an API
project and an identity server and we
will just wire it all up by magic do we
like this yeah is this what you wanted
yes okay so thank you for saying that
because this has been like a year of
work and if it's like no I don't want
that I'm just gonna go home and cry so
identity server is what we chose you get
your integration and if you're gonna
tweet anything that's the thing I would
love you to tweet because it will make
dominic and Brock very happy and instead
of me buying them dinner it might be the
other way around for a change
so
well that's glorious data protection so
I said that we we encrypt and we sign
things in authentication cookies and
this is how we do it this is pretty much
the same as last year nothing has
particularly changed so if you sat in
this last year I'm sorry this is pretty
much the same you've got your exciting
stuff with identity server I feel happy
about that
but we need somewhere to store our
encryption and signing keys and it used
to be in web config we had the concepts
of machine key which was a hard-coded
signing key in a config file how many of
you have ever had to change your machine
key okay if those people have had to
change it how many of you were in web
form scenarios where you had to change
it on every single machine at once it
sucked
this was not my idea web config was long
before I joined okay so you can't blame
me for that I know who you can blame if
you give me cash I might give you their
email address so we got rid of web
config as you're well aware because you
know nobody likes XML anymore and no
everything suggests but we we got rid of
machine key I'm replaced it with a data
protection layer and so what we have now
is automatic key generation automatic
key rotation we choose algorithms for
you we isolate applications
automatically we isolate based on
purpose we figure out where the key
should be stored best on app platform
which mostly works until you publish to
Azure and once you use slot storage and
slot swapping in which case it breaks
horribly because you're still haven't
given me that function after three years
of asking you can easily write new key
stores so you can match things to your
customers environments if they're not in
Azure and they have a sequel to invest
and they want to store all their
encryption keys in sequel you can write
your own and we can support custom
algorithms which is not for you it is
for Russia because Russia doesn't allow
you to use American encryption
algorithms anymore because they all have
flags
and they wear their flags so Russian
encryption algorithm which is ghost you
can write your own encryption algorithm
and plug it in we do not provide a gust
implementation for you because trying to
write one of those outside Russia is
interesting and the Russian government
can get quite upset but the custom
algorithms are there
it's the same with China China now wants
people to use their own encryption
algorithms as well so if you are trying
to sell a service to China you may well
need to wire up the Chinese algorithms
and there are new get packages for ghost
ghost and the Chinese one whose name I
can never remember and then you can just
wrap these things around but they are
not provided by Microsoft so here is
what we can fake how we can figure
things which is what your security
people want to know we do not hide this
away it is in the source code and that
if they go around and say well what's
the encryption and signing on this you
point them to this slide and that's what
we choose so it split up into two two
concepts we have a key store where we
store your keys and then we have
protection for that store so by default
you write your keys to a store they're
not protected they're in plain text you
have to layer on protection on top of it
so you want the two of these things
together and so we have key stores as
your web apps it's in a special synced
folder and by default that's our
unencrypted with iis with no user proof
profile well it sits in the registry and
now we actually use some windows
capabilities to protect it and i guess
with a user profile again we store it in
your app data folder and we use Windows
capabilities to protect it and we also
have an in-memory one which is where we
used to default to so we am data
protection and ephemeral data data that
you don't care about losing so how many
in memory is just fine until you had you
know like try and scale out and then
you're like it was in memory what do I
do and you have to switch to various key
stores and then we have protection
mechanisms so we have a couple windows
specific ones DP API and DP API ng then
we have good old x.509 certificate we
have a jerky vault support and then we
have plan text if you really don't care
then don't protect it
but if you persist if you persist your
keyring properly if you stick it in a
sequel database if you still get an
azure blob stories if you stick it in a
persistent Redis provider you can use
this for known ephemeral data but you're
on your own
we've tried to make it as foolproof as
possible because we realize people would
use machine key protection on their own
data and then complain to us when they
updated their machine key and web config
that their data didn't decrypt anymore
and we're like yeah because you change
the key did you keep a copy of the old
one no okay so we don't ever delete keys
anymore the keyring just grows bigger
and bigger and bigger but it's it's tiny
anyway I'm still getting blob storage
you're good it'll cost you like maybe
once two cents every month you can use
it manually like I say you just create
and data protector from it with a
purpose and you just call protect and um
protect and it will use the key rings so
here's how to do it like in memory the
ephemeral data protection brighter is RM
every one which we use in tests you read
things you call protect and then you
call unprotect and lo and behold we're
done purpose strings are interesting
they provide isolation so you really
don't want to use the same key for
different types of data so say I am
encrypting your credit card numbers
about example because you should never
be saving credit card numbers but will
will go with it anyway I want to encrypt
your credit card number and I want to
encrypt your email you should be using
different keys for each one so purpose
would allow you to say this is going to
be an encryption for credit cards with a
purpose of credit cards and this is
going to be an encryption for email
addresses with a purpose of email and
they have separate keys that are all
generated through all sorts of weird key
derivation stuff and they can't
unprotect each other there are a couple
of caveats here don't use user input as
the sole source of a purpose because
then a hacker can like say okay well I'm
gonna actually try and create a credit
card decryptor when you really wanted an
email one and that's not a good idea
and you'd probably want to like try and
version your purposes so as you change
things or as you change formats you can
change your
protect your format so there are
configuration points like I say we have
our key stores where we're gonna save
the keys we have how we're going to
encrypt stuff in those key stores and we
have key expiration policy which is how
long we are going to rotate thing
how long keys live for before they are
rotated automatically and if you want to
share key stores between applications
well apps are isolated by default so
there's an application name that you can
set and if you set it to be the same
then they can share and cripsy data
between the two and if you want to use
it in older asp.net applications we have
a forward compatibility pack we're not
doing back compact for this we're going
to drag you kicking and screaming up so
we'll skip past configuration and here's
how to implement a key store it's
incredibly easy you've got get all
elements and store elements and in 2.2
we will finally give you the red key
store that has been ready since - oh and
I just forgot to tell someone to flick
the bit to production authorization how
many of you were here for this last year
so some of you and you so I should go
through this again it's gonna be exactly
the same demo as last year that is route
to ginger people so you have that to
look forward to so I'm gonna run through
this I have an entire workshop for this
which is probably the best way to do it
it's it's maybe two hours worth of going
through and it talks you through
building things up step-by-step so we
don't want you to write your own
authorization attribute any more because
that was hard and it was wrong and
hard-coded things instead we switched
everything to policies and policies are
ways that you can express rules in code
based on requirements and we also have
given you resource based authorization
everything is done in DI we have our
custom scheme filtering which what you
should have been using to select stuff
but no we've got skiing four-wheelers so
use those if you want to make me unhappy
so we have things based on requirements
requirement is just a marker interface
you can put properties into your
requirements if you
so if you have like a minimum age
requirement and you want to spin up lots
of them you could have like a minimum
age in here that you could then set to
be like 18 or 21 bets don't what you
want to do and their requirements have
handlers and handler basically says ok
what what needs to be fulfilled for this
requirement to pass and I put my code
inside our handler so here we're gonna
check that someone has a claim of a
badge number it's been issue back in
toto and obviously you do more here you
check whether the badge is valid and so
on and if it is if it's correct then I'm
gonna say yep I'm gonna do task dot well
in this case it's tasked up from result
zero because I'm caring about back
impact to one but you can do tester
succeed and test out finish but the
important thing to note here is contact
stop succeed if your requirement has
been fulfilled you call contact succeed
and pass the requirement back and then
we build our policies up by adding
authorization and say in our policy so
here I'm creating a policy called
building entry I'm gonna add on your
requirement which is office entry
requirement and then you're gonna shove
our requirement handler into di because
everything is di based and then when I
want to authorize I'm gonna say
authorize policy building entry which is
the one that we can figure before with
our building entry requirement and it
will go into our handler and call the
code that you wrote in raiser pages
everything slightly different you can
set pages to be authorized and then you
can set the actual policy on the page
model so here we have our authorization
demo
I'm rapidly running out of time because
I got so excited about the API off thing
it is lunch after this right yeah they
always put me on before lunch because I
run over so I prepare to starve people
the workshop is a good place to start
with this so as you can see this is a
custom demo for Australia we're gonna
have the ability to change the weather
and choose whether we go inside or
outside and what the rules will do is
the policies that we set up will be
based on looking at the weather and
where we're gonna end up and who we are
and see whether it's safe or not so in
the minute it's winter so I want to go
outside I'm gonna choose who I am
how are you par ron weasley some weird
famous Australian chap I don't know so
well
we'll go to Harry par he can go outside
in winter that's absolutely fine because
we're checking who he is and the wet and
you know what the season is however if I
choose the late great Steve Irwin it's
it's winter and few people realize how
warm I two days outside right now and
yeah you're wandering around with layers
on it is hilarious but apparently you
know if it's less than 20 degrees no one
wants to go outside without six layers
on so in winter it is too cold for Steve
Irwin to go outside
so let's sign off Steve and we'll we'll
change it to all Z summer forest and
climate change so now it's summer so I'm
gonna go outside again I'm gonna be
Daniel Radcliffe
no you see now it's summer and British
people should not go outside in
Australian summers because they'll burn
okay but if I go outside I Steve Erin
it's fine because now it's summer and
it's finally warm enough for Australians
to go outside okay just watch out for
your drop bears and then you know what
we we have Rupert Grint and honestly cuz
he's ginger it doesn't matter what
season this is ginger people should not
go outside in Australia because it's too
sunny and you'll burn to a crisp so we
should look at the code behind this I
love doing this one because in America
they think ginger people are real people
it's it's really quite bizarre they
don't they don't understand this one of
my friends married a ginger last week I
went to the ceremony and then like
literally fled the ceremony to get a
plan to come here and got there like 10
minutes beforehand and before I went I
gave them both a big hug and I got a
text from my friend saying that his
partner was was deeply amused that the
guy hugging I went no it's fine you have
half a soul between you now it's okay
I'll hug them so what we have is do we
have required well we have requirements
so we have a location requirement that's
going to be inside or outside and then
we have an authorization for gingers
which is specific to for Ron Weasley and
we have a weather provider which is
where you probably go really enough to
your database so what we do is we are
going to add a policy for inside and
it's and we have a policy for outside
and we're gonna add the handlers for
those because it's gonna be the same
handler for multiple policies or for
multiple requirements they're all gonna
handle location requirement and the
collation requirement for gingers
basically says you can't go outside or
inside at all you're in Australia it's
bad for you whereas our normal
requirement handler will make it depend
on your nationality
it doesn't take hair color into a
go through the lab it becomes a little
bit more clear but I'll try and explain
it now so policies are made up of one or
more requirements and all the
requirements have to succeed for policy
to pass and all requirements are
evaluated just in case you want to log
and handlers are handlers for
requirements and you can have multiple
handlers so there are multiple ways to
fulfill a requirement and the way to
think of this is gain access to your
office if you have to swipe a badge to
get access to your office that is one
way of fulfilling your office entry
requirement but visitors need to come in
to so they get like little visitor
badges which don't swipe but the
receptionist will press a button but
their visitor badge is another way of
fulfilling the office entry requirement
so you have two handlers for a single
requirement and if either one is
fulfilled then the requirement is
fulfilled
and when it's successful you call
contacts that succeed when it's
unsuccessful you do nothing at all
because like I said there are multiple
handlers on a requirement so the next
one might succeed there is a context off
fail that is not something you generally
want to use it is for horrific
circumstances it's for that I need to
short-circuit everything it's like I
don't care if another handler will
succeed so my database is on fire
don't throw anything more but it's it
normally it's not something you will
want to call and you can do this
imperative Lee as well because
everything is best in DI you can take
authorization service into your
controller and call authorize async with
a policy name if you're inside a view
and you want to do things if it fails
just return you challenge result and we
will take care of all the prompting for
logins or the forbidden or unauthorized
stuff for you just always remember to
register your handles in DI if you don't
do that nothing is going to work and
you'll sit there going why is nothing
working and then you'll remember that
you have to rewrite your hand
register your handles in di and if you
are using databases of course just
remember to change the scope during your
di injection of the handlers we have
resource base authorization so say you
have a document and someone wants to
edit it you can change your resource you
can change your authorization based on
what that document is so it's like hey
you're the author of this document I'm
gonna let you edit it or you're the
admin of this SharePoint site I'm gonna
let you edit it so it's best in
operation again this is in the workshop
but you can do all sorts of funny things
so here is one that takes an
authorization Handler this time for a
resource it takes a requirement but this
time it's also taking the resource
itself the document and that will then
pass through to handle requirement
anything we've got our document I'm
gonna look at a property of the document
and then decide whether I want to
succeed or not here's how we add
authorization everywhere this will work
for rezar pages too and if you don't
like scheme forwarding and want to do
things the correct way although filer
will disagree with me then you can
actually limit by schemes inside your
policy and you can do things if you're
an NBC because the authorization service
is in DI and you don't want to use view
models because you're a horrible person
you can inject the authorization service
into your view and call authorize async
in your view and then show/hide things
based on the result doing a few models
for heaven's sake just remember to then
duplicate those checks on the back end
because otherwise people will just hit
your routes directly if you don't like
it you can throw it away this is what
policy server does they replace our
entire policy provider with their one
that then allows you to set rules based
in a database in a server somewhere else
so we're getting towards the end asp.net
identity is our database for storing
user names and passwords it used to come
with an awful lot of crud in the
templates because we have this lovely
facility now in MVC 2.1 to bundle
everything including UI
into and you get package we've done that
now so you know if you create a new
solution with identity you won't see any
of the identity controllers which is
great until you want to come to
customize things and you're like how do
I customize it well you right click and
choose scaffold I add new scaffold an
item and you will see identity in there
and it will extract everything I and lo
and behold you have all your controllers
and UI back again you can also use this
to add identity afterwards so you've got
a project and you're like oh darn it I
need a login
I need a login screen I need usernames
and passwords you can also just do add
new scaffolded item and choose HP don't
hide anything
we have gdpr points because everyone
likes those cookie prompts we are not
saying asp.net is gdpr compliant we are
saying that we can help you meet some of
your obligations there was an awful lot
more to gdpr than this my manager keeps
joking that he will stand up one day and
say if you use our templates you're
fully protected for gdpr
and he knows that's wrong but we'll give
you extension points in our templates
for data downloads and deletion we give
you extension points for encrypting data
at rest although for heaven's sake don't
use them this is the last possible
resort for this stuff this is when you
are using a database that does not give
you encryption at rest but you realize
you still need it use a database that
gives you encryption at rest it's so
much easier and it's transparent to you
and we have two-factor authentication
for your nice little TOTP apps and for
GD P are outside of identity we have
support for those annoying consent
dialogues once you start implementing
this it gets a little bit more
interesting if a user has not consented
asp.net will not drop cookies that are
not marked as essential so you have to
change you have to rethink how all your
cookies work and choose whether you want
mark something as essential or not and
be prepared to argue that they are in
fact essential when Europe comes down on
you with a great big heavy boot here's
our we start of wire up cookie policy
options we're going to check
whether consent is needed and that will
go away and look for something and
that's something is up to you and then
when we are creating cookies we can set
a cookie option that says something is
essential and in our views we can use
this to set the consent to being tracked
or using non essential cookies just by
dropping another cookie funnily enough
because that's the only way to do it
so that's quick run of where we went
that has covered things in one two to
one and what will eventually come about
two months after we have dropped to two
I am aware that I have run over by two
minutes so if anyone has questions and
hits everyone else in the room enough to
keep them from your lunch now is the
time to put your hands up or come sneak
up there is someone that hits you
there's a man at the back man at the
back what would you like to ask to keep
everyone from their lunch yes
so the questions about unit testing the
authorization policies and you say it's
very hard I would honestly argue that it
is not but that's just me because it's
you you you test the handler so you just
call authorized async you pass it in a
mocked up request and check what comes
out again no I think we need to talk a
little bit further about why it's why
it's hard for your circumstances because
there's probably something I'm missing
here like whether you have database
dependencies or or something else that's
slightly weird but in theory it is just
a matter of mocking up there are
creating an instance of the requirement
handler that has everything you want
mocked around it and then call it and
see what drops out the other end which
to me is easy but I must be missing
something so if you want to like delay
your food gratification and come up and
and have a chat I think that's probably
the best option does anyone else have
questions yes yes
so the question is if we are going for
the new fancy web API stuff and you
issue a token what do we use for private
keys for signing that JAL token we take
care of that for you
um we will we will we would always it
and how does it get distributed okay
that becomes slightly more interesting
we're gonna give you a key provider in
much the same way that you can do with
identity server right now we will give
you we will give you a one that looks
roughly like the data protection
providers so you can say I want to share
my key via Redis or I want to share my
key via a sequel or I want to share it
by blob storage that isn't my list of
things to do which is why it's going to
come two to three months after two point
two launches but we will be supporting
your skill like scenarios for this it's
just not quite there yet it's all hidden
away in a private repo that you can't
look at yet either give up give it a
week a week in half and it will all be
public and you can all start creating
issues like well a lot about this what
about that what about the other and make
Xavier really really sad does anybody
have any more questions or would you all
rather go for lunch
I'm terribly sorry around over you can
grab me over the next couple of days and
just pass to me about more questions
enjoy your lines thank you very much
[Applause]